[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the deathly hallows
the battle of hogwarts potion making
horistalk horn
and a little potion by the name of felix
felici's
liquid luck more specifically i'm going
to be addressing the question
why wasn't liquid luck used more why
wasn't it utilized during the battle of
hogwarts
if you've always wondered this as well
then sit back
relax and enjoy we first see liquid luck
in the half blood prince after
dumbledore has convinced professor
horace loghorn
to return to hogwarts and teach potions
in
this same school year harry paid extra
close attention in his class
hoping to be selected by slughorn in
order to obtain
information about tom riddle and
horcruxes
part of this selection however involved
harry's use of a certain
potions textbook one belonging to a
half-blood prince
the textbook allowed harry to breeze
through slughorn's potions lessons with
ease
providing him with all sorts of
shortcuts to a perfect
brew in one such lesson felix felici's
or liquid luck is introduced to us a
potion that
in essence enables the consumer to
become successful
in all of their endeavors felix felicis
is in my opinion the most powerful
potion of all
because its possibilities are seemingly
limitless
whatever you try to use it for you will
be successful at
which means that with it you should be
able to achieve almost
well anything the potion was first
created in the 16th century
by a potioneer by the name of sigmund
bridge
who dubbed it the crowning achievement
of his career
mine only invention my masterpiece the
crowning achievement of my career
bottled good fortune brewed correctly
the drinker of this potion will be lucky
in all their endeavors but be warned
excessive consumption
is highly toxic and can cause extreme
recklessness fans of quidditch were
quick to protest that a potion which
gives the drinker good luck
was hardly fair and use of my potion was
banned
quite rightly from all competitive
events
except potion making tournaments and
here harry was
installing class with a vial of this
potion right in front of him
a vial that looked like molten gold with
large drops leaping like goldfish from
its surface
never spilling the only thing that harry
needed to do
to obtain this vial of liquid luck was
be the first
to successfully brew a draft of living
death
which of course harry did thanks to
snape's textbook
later in the same book film we finally
see harry used the vial that he won
a vile that would have given him about
12 hours of luck
harry did not answer for a moment then
slowly
but surely an exhilarating sense of
infinite opportunity stole
through him he felt as though he could
have done anything
anything at all and getting the memory
from slughorn
seemed suddenly not only possible but
positively easy
he got to his feet smiling brimming with
confidence
harry ended up taking a small dose
enough for two
or three hours but in this short time
frame he was able to achieve
a lot including but not limited to
obtaining the uncorrupted memory from
horus slughorn about horcruxes
attending aragog's funeral keeping his
word to hagrid
convincing slughorn to accompany him to
hagrid's successfully casting a
non-verbal refilling charm on slughorn's
drink
even though he had not mastered
non-verbal spells
bumping into ginny leading to a compound
of events that led to ginny breaking up
with dean thomas
inciting the breakup of lavender brown
and ron weasley
and sneaking back into the castle
undetected evading even peeves
in short harry achieved a lot and this
was just
in two or three hours can you imagine
what an army of witches and wizards
would achieve
utilizing liquid luck for an extended
period the other side would stand
no chance right so why wasn't it used
we know that liquid luck is hard to make
this is emphasized in the book and film
but we do know that it's possible to
make slughorn made it himself
so why wasn't slughorn tasked with
creating liquid luck for the battle
surely it would have helped with well
everything contributing to the defeat of
lord voldemort
it seems to be praised as a rare and
powerful potion
but again slughorn can make it and it
can't be
that priceless if he was willing to give
it away to one of his students
surely someone would have asked slughorn
to make it
right why not first of all money can't
have been the issue
because both sides good and evil
have wealthy wizards that could have
easily contributed towards the
production of the potion
if it came down to a question of money
second of all it's not as if felix
felicis is this
secret potion that slughorn doesn't want
getting out into the world
it's well known in the wizarding
community it's even a banned substance
in sports like quidditch
lastly everyone knows that slughorn can
make it
he told his class and he's probably been
telling his classes
for decades to top all of this off it
doesn't seem like there's any reason
why people wouldn't be able to take the
potion on the day of the battle
i say this because when slughorn was
questioned on this by terry boot
he had this to say why don't people
drink it all the time
sir said terry boot eagerly because if
taken in excess
it causes giddiness recklessness and
dangerous overconfidence
said slughorn too much of a good thing
you know
highly toxic in large quantities but
taken sparingly
and very occasionally i can certainly
think of a time
when it could have been sparingly taken
by a lot of people on only one occasion
so again what's the deal first of all
there's a pretty strong chance that the
bad guys
used felix felicis at some point or
another as well
we know harry uses it and everyone seems
to know that it exists
slughorn even taught a lot of the death
eaters and even tom riddle himself
for them to not utilize such a potion
would make absolutely
no sense so i'm willing to bet that
though it wasn't included in the books
films the potion was used at some point
or another
in order to achieve something what
exactly
well that could be a separate video what
i think it probably really comes down to
is the brewing process
how feasible it is to make a lot and how
consistently you could make a successful
reliable batch sure felix felicis isn't
impossible to brew
and presumably most very gifted
potioneers
at least slughorn and probably snape are
able to make it
but that doesn't mean that it's quick or
that it's
100 dependable in snape's copy of his
textbook for advanced potion making
the one that harry uses he actually has
notes about felix felicis
he takes note that the ingredients felix
felicis is comprised of
are particularly complex and adds that
it takes six months to brew these two
factors alone
are great reasons for why it isn't used
or produced
in mass quantities or produced often
war doesn't wait for potions to be
brewed and i would imagine
that it would be a difficult and
dangerous potion to stockpile in large
quantities
imagine if it came into the wrong hands
the ingredients required for a
successful batch of felix felices are
ash winder eggs that come from a magical
serpent named ashwinder
which are purportedly very valuable when
frozen
stored squirrel bulbs which come from
the squill
flower mutt lap tentacles that grow on
the back of a
mert lap a magical marine beast these
tentacles are said to be
very rare a tincture of time a common
muggle herb an occamy eggshell which
comes from the egg of an occamy
a winged serpentine magical beast and
finally
pounded common roo an evergreen shrub
native to the mediterranean
most of these are not easy ingredients
to come by
but suppose you do get a hold of all of
them you're in the clear
right wrong in the half blood prince
slughorn emphasizes the precarious
and difficult nature of brewing such a
potion
desperately tricky to make and
disastrous to get wrong
however if brewed correctly as this has
been
you will find that all your endeavors
tend to succeed
at least until the effects wear off what
he doesn't mention here
however is how a witch or wizard would
be able to tell if a batch has been
brewed correctly or not
i think that the implication here is
that being experienced isn't enough
it can still go awry i think that it
might be one of the situations where
a witch or wizard wouldn't actually know
until the potion has actually been taken
which would make using it a significant
risk if it were to be doled out to the
witches and wizards
who fought valiantly in the battle of
hogwarts slughorn himself
once expressed that he has only taken
the potion twice
in his life have you ever taken it sir
twice in my life once when i was 24 once
when i was 57
two tablespoonfuls taken with breakfast
two
perfect days other reasons for why the
potion might not have been used include
it might simply not be appropriate for a
battle setting
the potion is cited to give the consumer
what they need
and not necessarily what they want in a
jewel with a death eater
you might want to kill them but in
reality all you really
need is to survive so the potion might
only help
with that the fact that it only works
from dawn to dusk
wouldn't it be disastrous if it all wore
off before the battle ended
people could easily develop an addiction
obsession with the potion
this is a potion that allows you to for
hours
achieve things that would have perhaps
never been possible i think that
something like this could be
particularly addictive
and the kind of thing that people would
do bad things
just to acquire what do you guys think
did you ever wonder why this
powerful potion was simply never used in
the battle against voldemort and the
death eaters
do you have a theory of your own comment
down below
until next time remember these are mad
times we live in
mad